this is a production of Cornell
University we decided that the organic
farming and today we got about a
thousand acres of the farmer
mechanically we actually the first year
that we did start we did start with some
organic or transitional provisions
exactly a year ago
very year we've had some great success
and we've had some failures also just
does Matt and Paul Simon
I think not at all so we weep on the
gamut point you plan alive
ladies also or I want to conventional
even though I think one year we
participated with 10 estate rotatable
handsome
and not much success and then a couple
years ago we planted 20 acres of those
billboards with the same exalted success
but we are I guess very interested in
no-till where we've used aspect know
organic farming I think that's one of
the issues that organic farmers in
general have telling us
each tillage but it's hard to do
the the other thing that we like about
news television is just my style all
myself
language is a great flavor savings as a
time factor we have for life owners
until within 15 follower of informants
still job duty equipment and time as a
factor and as most of you know in
organic farming time is crucial whether
you're planting cultivating whatever you
know it on whatever planet Earth Agra
time is very important it seems I just
added a point quickly built is it seems
like our windows for getting things done
planting management anything that's
almost any part of the year but
especially the spring is shrinking those
windows are just getting smaller and
you've got to get more done and less
than I'm finally the same not done and
less amount of time and you've got to
find you've got to have options you got
to have solutions you got to have as
Matt put it adaptive management but
seems like the window of opportunity is
smaller
is the approach the problems that we
have encountered one thing that I know
Steve domination our one thing we have
on this year's spirit village after
barley that develops critical machine
thinking that we got issues getting them
that materially so we need to establish
perhaps be exactly where you're just
telling up a script and making the rest
of the residue there and we have values
excitedly not only motivated to the soil
needs to be planted ever we get 35 acres
here the stretch has got some potential
that
be sure to establish the seat the soul
convicts they okay well I think well I
just I could skip around with the the
presentation here presentation here I
try to to modify it for this talk of
course on the itinerary there for our
talk
you know we're I guess focusing on
no-till cover crops and I would like to
definitely focus on that but maybe just
go through a brief overview of our
operation it's not too far into the
slides here but really we're gonna
highlight and we're gonna overlap a lot
conceptually with what Matt has already
spoken about and cloths also there's
just there's we probably could have all
four stuck here for about an hour and a
half and and did just being Punk back
and forth off each other and it would
have worked out pretty well but yeah
we're going to touch on a lot of those
same subjects and experiences have just
probably come at it from our perspective
down on the lower Eastern Shore of
Maryland or just look excuse me the
middle so Eastern Shore of Maryland
where we if they succeed things a little
differently or we just want to give you
a kind of example of maybe where we've
been where we are now and hopefully
where we're going to be going so to move
on here I would
you're late May and
lots of common oh just we see although
there's a lot there's plenty of
challenges but with every challenge it
seems like there's plenty of
opportunities with passing the two-year
rotation it seems like we lock in to
certain specific pest cycles will go
over those sort of things that
specifically when we're talking about
some of our no-till soybeans
predominantly a weeds our biggest pests
our biggest concerns right now and with
our later making and increased tillage
in certain situations general we seem to
have seen more aggressive annual
broadleaf weeds that we have to deal
with we're looking for different ways to
try to interrupt those pest cycles or
the weed cycles and that's where we're
trying to enter into using yes less
tillage minimum tillage minimum
disturbance sometimes no-till sometimes
different crops and the rotation to
break up those cycles something that's
for example peas peas that can be
planted much earlier and harvested in
just different times it will hopefully
interrupt like you said or disrupt those
test cycles especially if you're going
to be going into soybeans one of the
issues we've had three spraying spans
from the way is frame and it seems like
we're facing
we have great intentions of starting
planning for the 1st of May and you know
I did the mayor got our beans planted
and it hasn't worked that way and we
found we have a constant battle either
prop sent later than a color cross going
later than the next spring they come off
later in a system fights a never-ending
cycle but we've got Atlanta season corn
and harvest earlier we have rain systems
of the entire grain but there's still
have issues like I said it's all about
the timing and I think getting the cover
crops in and fall earlier is a great
asset and it just seems like we have a
hard time meeting that goal I think we
it seems like we've run the gamut of
just about almost every type of
situation that we can think of ourselves
I know there's there's got to be more be
more out there depending on type of
management your type of rotation and
even the crops but then generally for
our two-year rotation yes it seems like
we you know just going back to if we
have to go back to conventional tillage
we just seek still see the same problems
we don't seem to be even if you can work
the field several times and try to
diminish the weed seed bank we still
have aggressive weeds part of that what
we believe and I think is we of course
you farm a certain way certain rotation
you select for certain weeds it's really
answered biogenic selection you know as
the farmers you know you you've planted
certain dates you do operations with
cultivating work in the ground certain
dates you're going to select certain
weeds that fit into those little gaps
where you want working the ground where
they're gonna emerge and they can be
much more aggressive than the crop corn
or soybeans so that you've planted and
it's it's all about trying to find
another way to to find a way around that
or just find a way to least get your
crops
far enough ahead where you you have
other options tools in your toolkit to
address those weed issues other
challenges challenges Bill's touched on
management and labor cost of fertilizers
and trying to grow course our
our nitrogen for our corn availability
for some foreign sources of our of
nutrients sometimes can be an issue if
you're not trying to grow your nitrogen
or you go into a part of it we do that
every year on our
madacorp the next frame and we're we've
had a pretty good success doing that
bird growing I think anywhere from 60 80
pounds in the spring so that that
provides us about kind of Atlanta to
Leeds but we're going all the way we
ground us to clover suitable rings
that's your harder corn ground it's not
a barley or grain the rest of the planet
why this would just be a quick summary
of just our rotation our kind of a
traditional two-year crop rotation from
corn grain to fall cover crop light
planted after the corn and then the
soybeans whether it's you use the Rye or
not we will be planting soybeans
following that that rye we decide to
terminate it early or late and then
finally soybeans are they'll just
mentioned cover crop that's flowing on
it is a mixture of crimson clover and
barley that's really a really reason is
for it's a mixture it's we participate
in our state cover crop program and they
do require it weather though with the
legume to have a small grain mixed in
although some that we did we can will we
can debate that if we want a little bit
later if it's really necessary or not
and these are just some of the
operations we're looking at in between
for managing for cover crop management
between corn grain and far I depths of
color crop early is the best we will
repeat that just like you've heard
there's probably a lot already these
earlier sessions and in this room to be
arrow which is nice saved a lot of time
for us and those soybeans those soybeans
that haven't been cultivated
establishes a little nicer you have a
little more bare soil a lot of more
nooks and crannies for that small seed
to fall into and all you really need is
a little bit of precipitation and it
seems to take right off and probably
four out of five years it does pretty
well we've had years where we've had
poor crop spend maybe a poor winner
but in general it's usually a pretty
sure bet when it's flown on into a
cultivated
soybean field
now if you had if you were able to do
no-till soybeans and you still have a
lot of that right cover on we've had
issues with establishing that legume
barley mixture it's just because that
cover is still there that rye is
persistent it's supposed to be but it's
sent at tens do we get spotty uneven
stands of our cover crop and then
contact and several years we've done it
we've been planning
good
so and then so basically in this picture
here this is a slide year there it deals
with establishing the cover crop or
terminating it so and I talked to
obviously talked about an establishing
and terminating is if your rife you do
want to use the right but you have the
biomass you think you can make it work
roll down otherwise you got destroyed
earlier although that comes with its own
consequences we're probably talk about
that a little bit as we move along here
and took my time to proceed here and
with our corn grain if we're trying to
incorporate our corn grain trying to
release that nitrogen it's either been
plowing down or disking and we still
we're still it's a decision to make
plowing is slower a lot more intensive a
lot more I have an erosion issue you get
a big rain event disking it's a little
quicker although you might not get the
field conditions you like for planting
you got a lot of residue on the surface
area even with a decent planter you
might have some pest issues too we've
had issues with for example cutworm in
the field we thought it had a lot to do
with the residue still in the surface in
some parts of the field some of those
pests like to lay their eggs on the
residue and of course when plant your
crop in there of course that residues
only been incorporated two or three
inches that's your your seeds about two
inches it's right there amongst those of
those pests there they're there and
waiting for it so I threw this in your
groups real quickly as an as an
alternative something you could you
could stick in to possibly break up the
pest cycle starting there and with
instead of fall right we've done we've
put in fall barley one big reason it's
it's profitable extra money there's a
good price for it for organic barley
there's the demand and you do have to
fertilize you have to fertilize it but
what we've used before are a company
that we use that has some organic
fertilizer now they will they've done it
for a lot of dairy farms they'll put the
the seed the red clover seed in with the
fertilizer it comes out the booms it
sprays out that seeds small enough they
have the right nozzles they can
intercede when they your topdressing in
the spring and you can get a you start
your establish you establish your your
your crop in the spring and it's
very simple it's one less pass you have
to do it's it's very it's it's a nice
option for us and if the case is where
you want a summer fallow if you as long
as you the numbers work out on paper if
it's a farm you're you're not sure about
or you have you just have your point in
time in your season where or your
management where you know you've got a
lot of other you got other farms you got
acres you're spread out you just don't
want that that summer you just don't
have time like so the numbers work out
you'll summer fallow that red clovers
come on real nice you just have to mow
for weed management you know you have to
you have to kind of be a stickler for
that tried to tonight try to keep the
weeds down mow high keep the clover
growing and then instead of your crimson
clover that was flown on that will be
flown on the fall you already have
something established ready to go there
next spring and we've seen it produce
quite a bit of nitrogen for us I think I
include that a few other slides here in
the future so for us as I mentioned peas
we like it - it could spend good money
maker for us in the past it's good for
breaking up those pest cycles early
spring planting early summer harvest you
can still maintain your row crop cycle
you can plant you'd like to plant
soybeans after it the pest and weed
management typically when we were we fit
the field usually uh sometimes a flush
of weeds or if we can't control the
weeds as well as we want we know that
they won't go to sea by the time it's
ready to harvest a lot of those weeds it
might be till July before they're there
seed heads are mature and and you have
to worry about that but if it's being
harvested in June along with the peas
one of those harvesters come in that's
all taken off and you maybe have that
you the diminisher weed seed bank some
what we have tried spinach early fall
zone there wasn't a whole lot success
with this system the company pet wanted
that wanted to try it out I just don't
believe they had they had a lot of other
things going on they had a lot of other
conventional spinach Acres going on I
don't think they quite had the right
equipment they seemed to have a weed
issue here they were able to get one
cutting off and very late fall or
actually not early winter or December I
believe they took it off and instead of
getting another cutting in the spring
they just let it go
we went straight right into corn so the
peas and spinach alternative income it
can be pretty good the pretty good
moneymaker for us I said the numbers
have to work also you know along with
these other along with a lot of the
other things you know that we're looking
to and in the rotation in a whole farm
management system and in past cycles and
harvest well they can benefit for those
I think we could do better we've got a
crop occurrences and
we use everything just having a beard
this one I hear bill if you want to talk
about it it's just kind of a quick and
dirty breakdown of just the numbers when
we were you're doing either no-till a
soybean or conventionally tilled soybean
they own their $92 I prefer your net it
comes about
so that one reason the requirement was
best buy us later
yeah so just those are basically the
economics when you put that pencil to
the paper of course a lot of you know a
lot of what Matt's been talking about in
class and a lot of other speakers have
been talking about or some of those
figures you don't have a fine a good
grasp on or a quantitative number just
to put on paper but you know with a lot
a lot of the research that's been done
over the years and a little a lot of
with the work between farmers and
extension and university and so on and
NRCS we you know we know that there's
benefits there we've seen them we can't
quantify some of them in certain cases
some we can't but usually you can talk
to the farmer directly they can probably
tell you what works what doesn't and
where they see the benefits where they
can see room for improvement but we know
they're there but this is just to give
you a quick just quick overview of what
what we're looking at when when we just
try to put numbers of numbers down on
the page so basically the net income per
acre for a no-till $280 per acre versus
conventional 168 and that basically it's
due to this field operations the
difference there
really you only have a most your cost in
the conventional till as you're plowing
existing all your field work pullin up
the tractor pulling that equipment and
your labor to of course paying somebody
to do it and how it really adds up on
you and then then it comes down to your
net and we can see where we come out
and here's the other thing I'd like to
mention is about several people this
planet no utility the same time and
labor even if eagerly evolution less per
favore
just a quick overview of our two main
cover cut family the legumes and the
cereal grains course you legumes you got
your clovers vetch Cal P field P and
even the Sun health although we are
using really the clover red and or
crimson but kind of for two different
reasons
Nico grain rye barley we tried to try
some wheat this year have that planted I
have never tried to oats or trittye
triticale but and that can be popular
with certain systems like arrest and
organic dairy for chopping for example
but obviously that forage for dry seems
to have a market if you can find
somebody to sell to if they've got
animals you got an operation they need
it if it's a drought year like loss was
saying if you got it out there maybe you
can make it you can make something off
it and it'll all work out
Nebraska's grasses canola's canola
radishes radishes grass acid and grass
sort of today and until it warms see
them rye main characteristics is an
annual high biomass potential good
course weed suppression and that's due
to the ligneous nature at boot stage
crimson clover an annual winter hardy
most often more often than not very good
nitrogen production fast growth seems
like it's established it's pretty easily
we've we've broadcast clove around the
field and then drilled over it with just
our grain and it comes right up with it
it works pretty well so just cuz those
pressed wheels using a seven half-inch
spacing drill press wheels it just
incorporates it just into the surface
and as long as you get a little bit of
moisture takes off right with the rest
of it it's coming right up and barley
that's our other cover crop I'll talk
about that in a second
let's gonna move down here a little bit
there's a picture of some clover and
some like rye we're looking for biomass
weed suppression biomass for our legumes
you want money nitrogen so we're anxious
to combine that see that's made any
difference in the soybean yields
compared to the spring we are also
looking for maybe a way to perhaps give
us some little synergistic boost to the
the Rye of course we all know that I
would assume most most of us know that
legumes they fix nitrogen and of course
any crop with roots you know entangled
in the below the ground with it will try
to feed off some of that nitrogen and
perhaps we thought maybe if we've had
years where our biomass for a ride men
quite where we want it we said well if
at the very least it might give it a few
pounds of nitrogen while it's growing
and add to you know add a little bit of
biomass it might put us over the top or
we said we can go all in on a no-till
situation and even if it we didn't think
it gave a whole lot of nitrogen to the
Rye well we still have some biomass
although it's a little more fleeting
because we know that clover is more of a
succulent crop but give a little more
biomass to the whole system and then if
it rolled down it still might provide
enough time assuming everything else
works out in your favor for that crap to
get up and then you can and then maybe
you know your soybeans get ahead of your
weeds and then you have more beans than
weeds out in the field so a quick
picture of our our rig for no-till and
that was what we did this
summer with 150 acres of no-till we had
a pretty good rye crop and I don't want
to mention one thing if you can see over
here this field this is the direction
the field runs it's basically a big
rectangle and that's just a turn row
along a hedgerow but you can see our
angle for planting in the lands back and
forth back and forth passes at an angle
of course that's a with working with
Road out
Rodale and Bill when Bill first started
with organic of course we try to you
always try to roll at an angle that you
planted you're trying to overlap that
row of rye in to the next and so on so
it's covering between the rows where you
drilled so you're not trying to leave
any gaps at all I wasn't sure if that's
you talk that gets a whole lot of talk
but that's a one of it's one way we can
do it and it seems to work well it seems
to overlap doesn't leave to seem to
leave any gaps and provide some pretty
good coverage you can see that that
rolling was working pretty well you know
I tell you that tractor what's covered
up in pollen that's that's the right
that was the right timing I had to
change the filter covers many a time
because the tractor was getting too hot
but so the biomass 5,000 6,000 pounds
you know you can hope for eight nine
thousand but if you're in five to six
you're pretty comfortable I believe this
was I think between four and five
thousand we still decided to give it a
try it did lay over nice it looked like
it was heavy I guess a few issues with
that we had with it though the field
that it's all about may be your last
operation the previous season if you you
know if the what you've done before you
know it'll haunt you later on the field
maybe wasn't as smooth as it needed to
be
since the Rye was pretty thick and it
was it could be tough for the drill
dough to puncture through that biomass
but if you have gaps you have little
dips and divots and things like that
well the see might just be dropped right
on the surface if the field wasn't
smooth enough smooth enough you didn't
have that contact with the drill to open
that slot to drop the the soybean in and
then it just left it on the surface some
fields it seemed to do better than
others we're not sure why exactly but
that was a little bit of our experience
there
okay well should we just open for a few
questions or or does anybody have any
questions so far I should probably ask
that five ten minutes ago with or I
actually we have I'm gonna skip right to
it right now we tried we actually tried
a little bout of no-till corn we put
some please clover and rye in and had a
nice stand of here's here's a picture of
that but we I think we in the thrown
about 50 bushels of corn we actually did
not apply any other nutrients other than
we saw addressed with about 50 piles of
organic nitrogen and I'm not sure what
would have happened we had a beautiful
stand of corn we planted in 230 thousand
and their fertilizer camp
company came down checked and I think we
got twenty nine thousand plants but they
just I don't think they had enough
nutrients on it I won maybe one reason
for that it's it's still all speculation
we didn't have to take any samples we
were just had a busy year we were just
trying something to see what you know
see what would happen and you know see
if there was some merit to it and I
still think we still think there is but
we think sense basically going from a
conventional tillage system directly
into a no-till there's I think there's
some issues with your soil ecology soil
microbiology that just switching gears
immediately even with a good cover crop
a lot of biomass that's so that's the
picture on the right there that's it's a
lot of it's a good biomass with the Rye
and there was seem like there was a fair
amount of pee and a lot of clover mixed
in there but of course that a lot of
that material stays on the surface and
if you just don't have the the soil
structure and things working for you
underneath the ground I think with like
with a long term minimum tiller or
no-till situation you just you don't
have that capacity to keep that crop
growing I think we just ran out of
nutrients we just ran out of some
fertility
we a try there or not le yes Missy
underage though was a little too narrow
yeah it was tying up early because you
lose your corn yield is determined so
early with these new varieties you can
tolerate that early depression even if
you have plenty of that the rest of the
year that will be my guess yeah actually
makes some mixtures for just this
problem okay where he tries to remove
the grass and get the CN ratio narrower
as a way to make sure the corn is well
we know that Steve mirskiy has been
working on a awry vetch mixture and the
ratios play chutes the planting ratios
and seeing out how it turns out finding
that sweet spot where it gives you some
lasting coverage for weed suppression
but gives you the nitrogen that you're
looking for try to find that Goldilocks
scenario trying to reduce the amount of
grass right yes we try to minimize that
as much as possible all right good maybe
two more questions another question yes
well any any slugs with us the soybeans
on the bat Motel mulch yes they like
that you know that's one thing that
depending on your hiding you're allowed
to use slowly in an organic system using
some babies but made in an organic
system and that's a problem I will have
to pick your brain about that cloth
but we have like
but smoke devastated conventional
right very good
well that wraps it up all thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu